en España viven más de 870.000
marroquíes es la comunidad extranjera
más numerosa del país un 10% de esa
comunidad vive aquí en Madrid dos países
con mucha historia que hoy se enfrentan
en un partido de fútbol en el que para
muchos Puede que sea algo difícil elegir
quién vaya a ser el ganador lo que gana
mejor Pero yo creo que va a ganar
Marruecos
por no tenemos ninguna nocionado y todos
son jóvenes
encimador está está haciendo muy bien
pero la verdad yo estoy con Marruecos
que si gana Marruecos porque están mejor
nada más no por racismo
[Música]
el hecho de llevar 20 años viviendo en
España no hace difícil elegir entre
España y Marruecos en este partido
son iguales pero estoy a favor de España
pero ahora juega con Marruecos estuve
con Marruecos y hasta muchos llevan aquí
varias décadas algunos incluso casi toda
su vida de hecho algunos de los
jugadores son nacidos en Madrid como
ashraft hakimi pero ya que los Leones
del Atlas llegan por primera vez a
octavos desde 1986 Los Seguidores
marroquíes esperan que esta vez su
equipo le gane a España 3-0 porque en
2018 nos robaron y este año ya veremos a
ver si no nos roban porque yo que sé
macho
vamos a machacarles les guste o no Ya
nos toca a nosotros tener una estrella
pues me encantaría llegar una cosa
veremos en unas horas si son los Leones
del Atlas o la roja que hoy vestirá de
blanco quien alcance ese séptimo puesto
para los cuartos de final de esta Copa
del Mundo Qatar 2022